let's go to our headlines number one
president trump
yesterday unveiled something called the
1776 commission which he established
by executive order to promote patriotic
education as
as as he is selling it here he is
explaining it
today i'm also pleased to announce that
i will soon sign an executive order
establishing a national commission to
promote patriotic education
it will be called the 1776 commission
it will encourage our educators to teach
our children about the miracle of
american history
and make plans to honor the 250th
anniversary of our founding
think of that 250 years
now i i like the idea as we as you know
as we talked about yesterday i think
this actually uh it works with the topic
of the show yesterday uh
our education system as it is currently
run churns out people
who both hate and are ignorant of
our country and its history and its
traditions and this is unique by the way
this is this is not normal it would be
hard to come up with an example of an
education system
in any other country throughout history
that had the goal of turning
future generations against the country
itself
that's how our education system operates
that's not a normal thing
now granted the whole idea of having an
education system in a formal sense is
relatively new but even so
ours is suicidal and self-destructive by
design and it's good that we would do
anything to combat that i'm in favor of
that with that said two points number
one
um i would prefer if we called this
truthful education i think
truthful education rather than patriotic
education
because the problem with what the kids
are taught about america in
schools it isn't that the lessons are
unpatriotic
it's that they aren't true the idea that
america is fundamentally racist
um that's not an unpatriotic idea well
it is unpatriotic
but that's not the problem if it was
true then i would say
yeah kids should learn that kids should
learn the truth in school even if it's a
difficult truth
the problem is it isn't true so it's
untruthful
so i would prefer truthful education but
patriotic
education is okay too and the second
point is just
keep in mind and remember there is no
initiative
that can change the fact that our
education system is dedicated
to left-wing indoctrination that is what
it is
fundamentally at its core that's not
going to change at least not overnight
it will take generations that's a
generational change
and i know for me when we talked about
this yesterday i got some emails from
people saying well you know if you
abandon the education system and
and you're not fighting to change it
then you're part of the problem so you
know what
when you say fight to change it what
you're saying is you want me to send my
kids in
and have my kids fight to change it no
you know that's not my kid's job
my kid's job at the age of seven is not
to fight for changes in the education
system
it is my responsibility to make sure
they are educated
not their job to to change society
they're not they're not prepared for
that
they're not ready for that um so it's a
generational change but
frankly my kids are not going to be part
of making that change happen um
also by the way trump i wanted to play
this he attacked critical race theory
during
his remarks and the media didn't like
this at all let's listen to this clip
a perfect example of critical race
theory
was recently published by the
smithsonian institution
document alleged that concepts such as
hard work rational thinking
and the nuclear family and belief in god
were not values that unite all americans
but were instead
aspects of whiteness
this is offensive and outrageous to
americans of
every ethnicity and it's especially
harmful
to children of minority backgrounds who
should be
uplifted not disparaged
teaching this horrible doctrine to our
children
is a form of child abuse in the truest
sense
of those words yeah my only problem with
him calling critical race theory child
abuse
and a lot of leftists were upset about
that my only problem is that he should
have said
that it is putrid noxious garbage and
also child abuse
but what he said is totally true as well
unassailably true
uh number two from the daily wire 33
republican lawmakers added their names
to a letter that
representative jim banks sent to
attorney general william barr on
thursday urging him to prosecute netflix
for distributing child pornography in
the latest addition to the backlash
against
the netflix cuties movie which depicts
previews and girls in sexually
provocative situations banks and his
colleagues condemned the streaming
platform and called for them to be
prosecuted
uh and that's what they they sent the
letter to bar for i don't know if this
is actually going to happen
but it should and uh i've been saying
this for a long time
that standing up against filth and
degeneracy
standing up against the sexualization
and corruption of children
that is not only the right thing to do
um but the great thing is it's also
extremely popular it's an extremely
popular position
if only the republicans had the guts to
do it and finally it takes republicans a
while to figure this
figure things out but after a few
decades they've figured this out and so
this is good
number three lady gaga in another
courageous moment from a celebrity
has come out you're not going to believe
this
she has come out against white supremacy
i know pretty pretty pretty risky
position for anyone to take especially a
celebrity
so this from the daily wire says um
quoting her
i am in the process of learning and
unlearning things i've been taught my
whole life
wait i'm in the process of learning and
unlearning
things i've been so first she's going to
learn them and then she's going to
unlearn them
why not just don't learn them to begin
with and then you don't have to unlearn
them i don't understand this
uh she says when you're born in this
country we all drink the poison that is
white supremacy
social justice is not just a literacy
it's a lifestyle
none of this means anything nothing that
i just read means anything
she continues what do i think about
posting a black square
i think everybody has a different
feeling about it black square
do i think there's such a thing as
performative activism yes
do i think there's been true activism
that's been very important
yes do i believe black lives matter yes
do i believe this is going to get louder
yes do i believe it should
yes do i ask myself questions that
nobody else really cares about
yes the last one was for me not her
uh so a lot of very courageous positions
here
um just to just to summarize she thinks
black lives matter
um she's not in favor of white supremacy
and she thinks that uh that as far as
posting a black square
some people do it and some people don't
those are her opinions
bold number four now here's something
that's really bold okay let's go to real
here's some real courage the governor of
nigeria's kaduna state
has signed a law saying this is from the
daily mail by the way
saying that men convicted of rape will
face surgical castration
and anyone raping a child under age 14
will face the death penalty under the
new legislation
it follows public anger over a recent
increase of rapes amid coven 19
restrictions
which prompted the nation's state
governors to declare a state of
emergency
um the uh says one of the officials the
drastic penalties are required to help
further protect children from a serious
crime
i i would be absolutely in favor of that
in this country
you know i think it's it's sort of
absurd if you're gonna have capital
punishment
the idea that the only thing that can
earn the capital capital punishment is
killing someone
um there are crimes you can commit that
are
at least as bad as murdering someone
oftentimes worse
raping a child would be one of those
things
that's never going to happen here but i
would be certainly in favor of it
five finally this really could have been
my daily cancellation so it was it was
kind of a tie between this and the one
that i'm gonna do
uh so this is maybe this is daily
cancellation 1a
and i'll tell you what you're going to
witness here in this video
this video is the divide in america
right now
the two people in this video represent
the two sides of america
it's almost not even ideological you
have reasonable guy on one side and
insane harpy on the other
watch this may i ask um so i live in the
neighborhood
um and i have come to the cvs very often
may i ask why you called the police on
those two men
um cbs policy dictates that if they're
shoplifters
the exit store with merchandise unpaid
for it yeah we should get the police
involved
and if the police apprehend them
okay so i actually did not elect the
press charges i said hey look i just
wanted to know they can't come in here
anymore
because they shop with you and i just
need them to sign that and i remember
collector
and the officer supplies and the guy
said same thing thank you
it's not your merchandise it's the store
so you know what happens when the
pokemon
or black people and you decided to call
the police on two black people that
stole
that allegedly took something from the
store
because you're willing to uphold the
policy and they could have lost their
lives
we can agree to disagree on this because
i don't work for you and i don't need i
follow my company's policies not your
policies where i can appreciate concerns
so you're willing to risk someone's life
for
what thirty thousand dollars a year
that's there was no risk in my opinion
thank you you have a great night what is
your name
my name is store manager no what is his
name
no one's gonna tell you my name when
you're sitting here videotaping us so
that you can try and
enlist there's some sort of violence
it's not gonna happen elicit violence
against you
you just elicited violence against two
black men by calling the police on them
so we got to walk away when one of them
had a warrant it could have been
arrested and the cops still let him go
just
listen to yourself you work with black
folks you just remember that
yes you see if if um if somebody commits
a crime
and you call the police and they get
hurt
probably while assaulting the cops it's
your fault for calling that's the point
that that woman was trying to make
now this is this is obviously insane if
you find yourself
sympathizing at all with the woman in
that exchange
and not with the guy who is i mean that
guy give that guy a raise
uh he's he's a manager for cvs he's not
paid to deal with this
but um this guy is incredibly reasonable
articulate
and explains yeah patient as well
way more patient than i would be this
guy deserves a massive raise
but if you watch that exchange and you
find yourself
at all sympathizing with the woman then
you need to reevaluate your whole life
but you are but that that's the side
you're on and you you're
there's a very clear dividing line here
it is it is
good guy bad guy and you see in that
exchange there there's a very clear good
guy bad guy
um but there's something more insidious
going on here
it is the first thing that came to mind
when i when i watch this
because keep in mind that in some of
these high-profile police shootings
the one in lancaster uh for example
kenosha with jacob blake
another example and others as well
very often it's a it's a woman it wasn't
the case here but
but very often it's a woman who calls
the cops
because she's being threatened or abused
by a man
so then the person in this video and
this this is what you hear from black
lives matter and antifa as well
this is a common attitude but what is
she saying
she's saying apparently if you're a
woman being abused by a man
don't call the cops but if he because if
he gets himself
shot when the cops come because
he's a violent lunatic then it's going
to be your fault
i mean how many women who are faced with
the next
jacob blake will hesitate to call the
cops
because they know with their based on
their experience with this man
that he's a violent lunatic and if the
cops come then he might get himself shot
and so the woman's going to worry well
if that happens you know my life's going
to be over too because everyone's gonna
blame me like this
this this crazy woman and people like
her are gonna blame me
uh so that's something that that i
really worry about but again there's the
dividing line in america just decide
whose side are you on thank you for
tuning in to the daily wire one of the
fastest growing conservative media
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video
be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content